oh do you have a list of all your
appearances on every single one and then
actually i have a little addendum that
says ways that i've died slash been
abused
this is fantastic both on and off screen
what were your favorite ways of dying
let me look at the list of ways of dying
uh hit with a dumbbell i've been shot
multiple times
i've been punched i've been drowned in
an aquarium i've been pepper sprayed hit
with a bat hit with a bottle
i had
my dreams sucked out of my head by a
monster
which would probably end in death stung
by bees i've been hit with a wrench i've
been sprayed by a whale
run over by the desk
mauled by a bear ground up in a meat
grinder this was all one sketch this is
one sketch oh the meat grinder i
remember that oh my goodness
yeah sorry keep going keep going morning
i mean then it's just like jesus throws
a fruit tray in my face i mean just like
that was just some weird weird stuff but
i was just like okay let's do it after
each one conan was like you know what i
like your stuff
really funny nice to meet you sorry
every sketch ended with jack mcbreyer
dying
i would start getting paranoid
i guess i'd do great death scenes i
didn't care i really really liked it and
plus all of y'all were so nice it'd be
different if it was like a bunch of
douche bags but like it was always fun
to come to work
and i'm sure that there was a lot of
stuff you know y'all had late nights and
all this kind of stuff but for me to
just come and play and then get paid for
it and then get that bacon cheeseburger
i was like i was
oh i was king of the hill i really
really enjoyed that time which you need
to deduct from your income tax because
of your accounting
i itemized everything
and i will say this i mean like that was
a point in my life
i don't think i've i've ever been shy
about the fact that
i am a person who might not be built for
life in new york city for very long term
um so i do prefer just the pace in the
sunshine of los angeles or anywhere else
but i have to say
when i was younger
and strangely when i didn't have any
money
i treasure those days in new york city
more than even later you know after
several years of being on a network tv
show and having a paycheck
i had more fun
just being broke and coming to do bits
with y'all right and then staying up
late for dumb improv shows you know it
just and i'm sure youth is the yeah the
equivalent of all that but um but you
also feel like things are starting to
percolate you know so it's true it's
true you do feel like oh i'm getting
traction you know it was just a point in
your life that it felt good i was
surrounded by a great community of
friends and and talent and
yeah i really i look back very fondly on
those days oh
it is kind of an unusual city especially
for new york city i think to have like
you know you had this great improv group
you could work with plus this tv show
that was using you all the time that's
kind of uh three times a week yeah yeah
like you joke but like it was pretty
fantastic y'all kept me afloat y'all
paid my bills and i was so proud you
know i was just like
i had arrived at that point right you
know
and then you go on to do like a network
tv show and like oh that's adorable oh
now i've arrived yeah yeah i was doing
you all a favor
that was so exciting when you were in 30
rock because
now we'd have you do cameos and all that
it was a totally different thing yeah
you were instead of kill maybe we kept
killing you i don't remember
jack with prayer now in the crowd yeah i
know it's uh it's been a treat um well
yeah i was wondering if that was how the
conan staff found out was they tried to
call you in for a a small bit and you
were like um i'm on
sweetie sweetie honey honey sweetie no
okay so actually the conan crew comes in
to play with me getting 30 rock you want
to hear that story oh yeah for sure okay
so
i lived in new york from 2002 to 2005
doing bits for conan doing my ucb having
a blast after three years i was like
this has been fun
i'm broke and i'm freezing cold and at
that point you know snl wasn't buying
what i was selling i've done my kona
bits i've done my ass cap i was like
okay there's not too much more i can be
doing right now and i'm freezing cold
all the time move to l.a lost my tan to
be broke and tanned and so i was out
here and i was hustling and i was here
for about a year had to come to
new york for like an improv festival or
something so it would have been
july
of 2005.
i was back here
uh back in new york and at that point
tina got wind that i was in town she was
like hey
we're doing auditions for the untitled
tina fey pilot you're in town would you
swing by the casting office and put
yourself on tape i was like yup yeah so
i knew the role ken at the page and i
don't think it's any secret i think tina
had me in mind when she wrote the role
of kenneth
yeah so i was like okay i need to
crush this audition what do i do
you know they made me dress up like a
page
on more than one occasion over at conan
that's true surely they have a page
jacket that fits
called up the conan uh page desk
had them uh send me to wardrobe y'all
lent me a page uniform
your makeup department put a little
color on my face
and i
auditioned dressed up like a page so
somewhere in the archives of 30 rock is
my audition tape
using the conan page uniform and wearing
cone and makeup oh i guess i might have
just threw some people under the bus i
owe somebody money now
and that helped me get the job it's me
god i would be curious to see that
footage except i wouldn't because i'm
sure i look like an infant i don't you
look the same now i think god stop
fishing yeah
uh but yeah it was because of my
connections at conan that y'all hooked
me up that's great and i think that
really truly that helped me get the gig
because y'all know i can't act right i
love she wrote the part with you in mind
yeah knowing the executive producer and
having it written for you had nothing to
do with it but it was the jacket that
sealed the deal
it all helps it all helps